Hãy các mình một tóc bán này, nó là tên xin vinh các bà đổi và các bạn cân, mình còn luy gì để học tốt các môn học
cho chúng ta xin các bà, y sẽ đẹp video này thì có thể tổng thập cho các bạn nhé
Đi đầu tiên nó là 2 cái mình một phải thay tầy đổi, tâm thể học tập
Hãy cho khi mà các bạn học các thay thì các thay của ta còn quan tâm dư rát
Gái nào hỗ trợ giúp lưỡa cho các bạn, trong lớn thì cũng xúc lượng các bạn ít hơn
Lấy cái thay của thay của ta trong xóc, các bạn bị điểm kém, cái thay của nhất nhỏ rất là nhiều
Mọi người các bạn có chuyện khoảng 20, hơi khác của chút
Thế của các bạn xà hơi xà cái chuyện khác hơn không đơn giả, hơi hơi hàng tuần đâu, và viên lý xói như vậy,
cho nên mất một các bạn khi học các bạn phải không có cái năng lực tổng thật tốt
Nói không tự chịp xanh nghiệm với cả, và chính hỏng tập của mình để làm xà mình học tật cho tốt
Không còn là đi đồ nấu, nhất nhỏ, xuống gái thúc dụng các bạn thật tỏng đâu nhé
Kính tất cả tốt xin các bạn này không và một lý lất mời, nói riêng, là những kiến thức phát nổ sẽ năng cao hơn vào xa hơn sau nên kính thức mật cả hậm
Nói xong chuyện xin ở ta lực chiến, hay là chuyện xin trò kức xo
Trước khi trò kức xo thì kính tất cả tốt là trọng, dây giờ mình có trọng tốt là một lộ các bạn đồ cao hơn rất nhiều
Lời hoa biết trong của mối mối lùi tiếng học các bạn cones này có một sự tập trung nhất định
Nếu như mà có thông ơn sự tập trung này thì rất là dễ ngọt thì tục điểm số rất nhàng,
đúng không? Này, sau mà như mà thông xin cũng trang lưới các bạn nhé.
Thìu xong mà đó là 1 thọt có trung xin mới đi lắm mới thì các bạn cần bị điểm,
cho mình 1 lộng xin học tập, thật là bài bản.
Trước khi chúng ta bắt đầu với bạn đâu nó không?
Này, bình thường là tiếp thu hình kế tất nhiên trên xe không thì vô cùng là tử lọc.
Thế cô giọc thì các phía bảo thông xanh, ra bảo đậm nào bảo thông xanh.
Nhưng mà khi như bài của nó phút thì nào nó mìm cao được.
Điểm cao rất trang là lất.
Với năm nay thì thì thành cũng sẽ có một lộng xin học tập vô cùng bài bản.
Phán chó tất cả, xin 2 cao mì một mô xo bắt xe,
tư性 bởi lắm bời, rởi lộ xin lưỡ viết năm nay.
Đi sẽ lộ xin năm nay thì các bạn học với thầy gì vô cùng xứng rồi.
Đi sẽ tìm lĩnh hết cho các bạn, mình không chức hình học này.
Bài học này.
Giác bài này.
Đi sẽ lịch học hàng cơn, chúng ta sẽ có xe phỏa xin học tập.
Và nếu như các bạn, khi lộ xin học tập tập tập tập,
tệ tự tiến là tệ giúp cho các bạn.
Nạn ở điểm cao và cảnh đều số rất tốt trong năng học sợ tựa khi bắt đầu lên các bạn.
Nếu như bạn nào mà mùa quan tân mình lộ xin này,
nhanh tý trực tiếp về bài phái xai, thì nó thành chứng viên.
Và nó hốt là cho của lịch tiếp từ bình chức các bạn.
Măng ký để tỏa vào lớn cương nhé.